Jay Armstrong: I took all the pills that I had...
I took 'em all.
Jay Armstrong: Hi, my name is Jay Armstrong.
Matt Peterson: My name is Matt Peterson
Justin Ponton: Justin Ponton.
Kelvin Young: My
name is Kelvin Young.
Justin Ponton: The first time I'd
ever used any substance at all I drank
with a couple of friends of mine. And I
tried marijuana the same time. The
heavy substance abuse really happened at
the age of 21.
Sally Satel: Prescription opioid abuse
is a lot more complicated than the media
and politicians make it out to be.
Jay Butler: Too often, sports-related injuries managed
with opioid pain relievers have been the
beginning of a path to addiction.
Sally Satel: It's true that some people who get
prescription opioids from their doctors
do become addicted to them. But the
majority of people who abuse opioid
painkillers typically get them from
their friends, relatives.
Jay Armstrong: So I'm 14, 15, 16 years old,
and the guys I'm hanging out
with they're all 21 to 30 years old. At
one point they broke out some Dilaudids,
which is a pharmaceutical opiate that
you can break down and inject. And it
took me to the same place mentally and
emotionally that alcohol did. But I
didn't, you know, try to fight anybody. I
didn't puke, I didn't pee my pants, I
didn't try to take my clothes off in
public or any of the other crazy stuff
that I was doing with alcohol. And you
know, at the time it was like a miracle!
Like, oh my god, like why didn't we find
this sooner?
Sally Satel: The fact is that many of
these individuals already have
experience abusing drugs, from alcohol to
marijuana to inhalants to drugs like valium.
Kelvin Young: For me I started drinking when I
was about 13, 14 years old.
So by the time I reached age 26, 27, I
"graduated," so to speak,
to cocaine and heroin.
Matt Peterson: So at 13 I started
drinking and smoking pot, and then...
probably about two years later, cocaine
was introduced. The first time I abused
opiate painkillers, I had my wisdom
teeth taken out and my friends they
taught me how to crush up a pill and
then snort it.
Justin Ponton: I started selling prescription pills.
I was selling cocaine,
crack, heroin, weed... anything I could
pretty much get my hands on. And then I
started using the drugs myself.
Sally Satel: At least half of all individuals whose overdose deaths are attributed to an opioid also
have some other drug in their system at
death. And it's these drugs in
combination that are especially deadly.
Jay Armstrong: I didn't plan on living another second, so
I didn't try to go to a place where I
could hide. I took all the pills that I
had. I took 'em all. And I did all the
heroin that I got, because I know mixing
benzos with opiates does the trick, you
know... and it should have done the
trick.
Sally Satel: People who use drugs of all kinds are people who are trying to medicate some
sort of deep inner distress. It doesn't
mean they're bad people. It means they're
desperately looking for a way out and
can't figure out anything but drugs.
Justin Ponton: A lot of the reasons why I did initially
begin to use substances was a lot due to
low self esteem, no sense of self-worth
and insecurities.
Jay Armstrong: The theme of my childhood is that
I didn't feel wanted, I
didn't feel like I belonged, and I felt afraid.
Kelvin Young: Growing up as the youngest
of five... I felt different. I felt
less than. When I did heroin... I felt good.
You know, it numbed that feeling of...
feeling less than, inadequate.
Matt Peterson: Me growing
up as an only child, the son of a pastor...
I just wanted to fit in. But when I smoked pot
and drank for the first time, I felt felt accepted.
Sally Satel: It's true that doctors have
over-prescribed opioids in the past and
now they've been cutting back since
around 2011 and this is a good
development. However, what doctors do in
their office will have no effect on
people who never got the prescription
opioids from their doctors and it also
has unintended consequences for patients
who truly are in pain and need those medications.